story out of Philadelphia over the
weekend a mass shooting during the
holiday Southwest Philadelphia five
people dead and surveillance video on
your screen now appears to show what
happened a gunman opening fire on an
everyday City Street Philadelphia police
have confirmed that the video you see
here is part of their investigation but
they've declined to comment further and
they say the suspect who is in custody
had no connection to the victims who
range in age from 15 to 59 two children
were wounded in this attack but
fortunately they are now in stable
condition the alleged gunman had an AR
style rifle and a handgun when he was
arrested he has not yet been officially
charged and we still don't know about a
motive